I did it it was totally mean I stink but
it was the same in Brussels
Oh
whoo good zoning coming out just like
you wants to for throwing the matches
are really ultra teleport and also with
the teleport is you can actually phase
in the same place as well so you can
faisal behind the opponent or you can
just stay in the same a teleport is
great too because it also it has armor
yes
so the e^x versus oh right yeah there's
a lot of special moves pretty much every
button has the least two special moves
attached
oh stop it so he's here brother man
ketchup keeps trying it but the anti-air
flamethrower is not working just well
maybe you shouldn't wake up and he's
just living it yeah oh nice
swaggy no showing some respect there you
can definitely I mean obviously by
watching to tell if this is this matchup
for probably happen it's got a thousand
times with these absolutely and also
kudos to the audio guys like listening
to the metal pound is it each hint it's
amazing guys oh wow it just goes on and
on oh alright you know the fatality oh
we're going back to this one huh oh he
used you to kill you that's weird
yeah that's dark that's alright so this
is for all of it
you